[Music]
hey everyone we're here at the
infrastructure migration zone of Google
cloud next I'm mark ports and Donnie I'm
here with suma
sure enough we heard a lot today about
anthos what is anthos why is it so
excited anthos is incredibly exciting
for us at Google cloud we announced
anthos as cloud services platform just
over eight months ago and today we're
very excited to announce general
availability of anthos for our customers
to be able to use it
anthos is our hybrid and multi cloud
platform that gives our customers the
ability to build once and run anywhere
why is hybrid and multi clouds so
important right now
that's a great question mark so hybrid
and multi cloud has been on top of mine
for a lot of our customers they're very
very excited about the ability to use
clouds but oftentimes what happens is
when they're running something on Prem
but running something else in the cloud
it becomes hard for them to manage these
different deployments that make them
segment their workforce into engineers
who are working on different things
instead of focusing on innovating for
their customers so that's why hybrid and
multi cloud is very important and it's
very important to have a uniform
platform like anthos that lets customers
run in a uniform way across the board so
we're talking about standardizing making
sure that everyone's on the same level
for people who are here at the Showcase
they can come interact with this booth
what does this tell people who are
looking at what does anthos do for me so
what we have in this demo is we've taken
the analogy of a city and how it works
and we've used that to show how hybrid
and multi cloud is very important and
how anthers helps in that particular
analogy so let's get started so we have
these three things that you can do over
the course of this demo first let's
start off by modernizing your services
there are multiple reasons you would
want to modernize your service for
instance it gives you a lot more agility
and speed and lets you deploy faster so
in this demo there are two options for
how you
can modernize your applications you can
either containerize them manually or you
can use CSP migrate which is now called
and force migrate to be able to migrate
these applications automatically from
vm's running on prem into containers
running in the cloud so for the sake of
this run-through let's select
modernizing with fellow startup which is
and throws migrate so bellow strata
automatically container eise's your VM
based workloads and will deploy them to
gke running in the cloud so just as
easily as that you'll have all of your
via VMs now move to the cloud as
containers and now let's look at the
second part we also help you standardize
config management using anthos config
management what anthos config management
lets you do is it lets you take a single
configuration and deploy it across the
board declaratively and uniformly
without you having to go and do it once
at a time per platform so no matter
whether you're running only on Prem in
Google cloud or maybe even with other
clouds you can do this all at once right
so now it's all standardized so now it's
all standardized and so for the third
part of this demo there's something very
exciting for me which is a service mesh
a service mesh is basically a mechanism
that lets you look deep into the traffic
that's actually flowing between your
applications whether they run on premise
or in the cloud in this case what we're
going to do is we're going to use anthos
to implement a service match between on
Prem wheel here and the two cloud wheels
that we have and by doing this we are
able to select a service and we're able
to say that let's upgrade the service
now when you upgrade the service you
pick a new version that you want to
upgrade to but instead of upgrading
everything at once what you're going to
do is you're going to select a small
percentage off your VMs or got loads and
upgrade them at once so when you do this
and you upgrade these containers at that
point in time you will upgrade just that
20 percent so that you see everything's
running fine and you don't have anything
broken and once you are confident that
this service is working well you can
upgrade everything else so this means
now we are able to roll out applications
with limited downtime to almost zero
downtime for your customers so you can
see how anthers uses open source
technologies but also this idea of
standardization to really bring it to
everybody yes
what's an example customer or concrete
use case that anthos has right now great
question so we have a lot of customers
who've been very excited to use and
thoughts and they span multiple
verticals
like for instance HSBC from retail and
banking and Siemens who's a giant when
it comes to manufacturing are also
looking at anthos as their platform of
choice for doing peyote and their IOT
platform so there are multiple customers
across verticals like retail and
healthcare who are very excited about
this platform and love that ability to
standardize and have a uniform plan
perfect well thank you so much tree nap
I'm sure there's gonna be tons of great
content here about anthos and lots of
other stuff ago about Nexus stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
you